right sure we're not kitten around here
it's world lion day and as you can
imagine the day
well of course it's all about the big
cats the campaign raises awareness about
lion conservation
around the world and you may not think
about lions here in southern nevada but
you can see them
right at the line habitat ranch in
henderson you're looking at video right
there
the non-profit sanctuary allows families
to feed the animals
and take pictures with them i don't
think you can hand feed them
no guests must buy an online ticket
and sign a waiver to go inside you could
just wander around and look at them
inside their cages too you know you
don't have to get up close and personal
unfortunately they're not open though on
tuesdays and wednesdays so
you can celebrate a belated world blind
day starting thursday and through the
weekend i don't think you'd be lying if
you say the lions won't mind if you put
off the celebration by a couple days
they'll be probably not
they're going to get fed in the meantime
they'll get an extra nap in there